what happened to jess
yeah what happened happened
something very traumatic has happened to
me that's something very different
actually that's true something i will
never get over yeah more traumatic than
childbirth yeah
[Laughter]
damn who hates babies morning i don't
even know
hi little baby
[Music]
hola putas it's me
gina it's me
with the rest of my crew a big mood
everybody say hi
hi
as you can see we are all on
our in our respective homes
because you know people are far away and
people got babies and whatever i don't
know some people got babies some people
got just some people i don't know who it
is sound off for the people who are
listening and not watching who's here
tiff's here
nicki's here
and jess is here i know you guys thought
i was gone
um this is the first time that we've all
four recorded an episode since like
early january yeah i was still still
pregnant no before that because gina
wasn't in our january episode oh right
oh yeah
like just some time she had a hard scare
yeah she was there where she wasn't you
know yeah so i felt like she was there
yeah
that's true that's true so it was like
december since november because we
didn't do december episodes you're right
you're right
and like it's been so long like
actually we haven't even met the baby
yet i know
what the heck
yeah only
i was trying to have him like for the
beginning of this episode but he was not
having it we don't you guys don't want a
screaming baby in your ear yeah
i know we already have gina yeah exactly
that's all you need i don't even know
why you had another baby when you
already have meat and then that's so
true i mean yeah i drink my milk already
so you are my daughter technically oh my
gosh i did i did we drink
breast milk me and nicki blaze it was
awesome it's so sweet
it's like really sweet it makes me want
to gag so bad
it's like
interesting
it was an inch like like a cantaloupe it
did taste like cantaloupe yeah i just
want just i want jess to have been in
there so that she could say things like
that and then inevitably try it because
she feels yes
i was just thinking i'm like okay for
our vegas shoot because we're sleeping
over or you guys are sleeping over
nicki's house in the morning when uh
when jess has her coffee i'm sneaking
some breast milk i don't know
i don't put it up in my coffee
i would be like why is this [ __ ] cloudy
no it's going to be in the starbucks cup
all clothes you're not i think it's
usually illegal to put bodily fluids in
without someone knowing or their consent
but
if you don't find out and get caught
true
letting her know
they let a lot of things slide
yeah
that's fine we're fine
but today's episode is a catch-up video
we're just gonna catch up with each
other you guys know what's going on our
life
let you guys know what's going on with
that dumb baby that i love
let you guys know what's going on in at
nikki's place where it's a thousand
degrees probably and let you uh you guys
know what's what happened to jess
yeah what happened happened
something very traumatic has happened to
me that's something
that's true something i will never get
over yeah more traumatic than childbirth
my birth was kind of traumatic to be
what it was oh my gosh you guys need to
catch that episode yeah
let's start off with nikki nikki what's
going on over there oh my god oh my god
my hands
so
okay last time i just moved here um yeah
so it's everything is it's good it's
vegas life is oh my god my life is so
different this is my office
so pretty much thanks you're rich now we
get it these are really high there's
just a lot of rooms a lot of hallways
you get really lost in here um it's a
such a nice pool day today it is almost
a thousand degrees but it's like a
perfect thousand degrees it's like 80
degrees out and
everything is blue skies perfect weather
and i was very tempted to ditch this
episode and jump in the pool and not be
found you could just [ __ ] leave if
you want if you don't want to be here
thank you i need you to validate me yeah
actually i'm not down i'm not ready i'm
not about my daddy
just left because we didn't validate her
enough yeah i needed any constant
validation the first thing she said when
she jumped on today was like can we like
be friends again like actually because
we like never talk anymore i know like
she was all accounting [ __ ] though so
like
like she was the one that was like i'm
playing company volleyball and doing and
i'm accounting all these
things
right i'm auditing people i'm like [ __ ]
i've been auditing a cr a crypto mining
company so you should be proud of me oh
my gosh
please don't audit my crypt
company no it's a company that wants to
be audited they asked me to audit them
oh i see you have to get an audit if you
want to be a public company so there are
there are crypto mining companies that
are going public they need an audit the
sec requires it and i've been learning a
lot about bitcoin because that's the one
that they're mining so it's pretty cool
look at you in the crypto world
i love the natural lighting over there i
love that nikki always has like
decorations like her
drawers and shelves are actually filled
up with decorations mine would just sit
empty for forever yeah this is a murphy
bed i had to build it last week i was
freaking out it's so comfortable because
it has the purple mattress which shout
out to our sponsor i don't think they
sponsored this episode but it's so
comfortable and my parents just uh
checked out the house for the first time
this past weekend and this bed was super
comfortable and um i like that it
doesn't like take up any of my office
when people aren't staying here but uh
but yeah i have all these knickknacks
that i was like i just sporadically
threw them on the shelf um but you can
see pillows down here because of the
murphy bed and i also have crystals on
this side um
but each uh iteration of my office has
just become like
a step up from the previous iteration so
last my last place i had that built-in
shelf stuff and like pretty much all
this stuff was on there
how's steve's bathroom
i don't go in there
i did make him clean it because uh
people were coming over but yeah i don't
i wouldn't trust it
murphy beds work like do you have to
like cut a hole in the wall to fit the
bed no so this is all like um i ordered
this off wayfair and it came with the
shelves too oh perfect so but it's cool
because the way that this office is
built there's this part sticks out so it
looks like it should have just built in
anyway yeah
yeah exactly it's exactly flush with the
wall and then um
yeah let me show you hold on what is
where's the the traffic toddler that
comes with wayfarer
that comes with late failure
the fbi just like checked into our
episode i know you're like what
nikki's pulling down her murphy bed so
we can walk so we can see what it looks
like i love how everything you see oh
she's got a decoration
perfect she's modeling
her whole body not for free
if you're on audio you have to view this
like a patreon
nikki you can't be showing that all for
free girl yeah
go to our patreon
we need money our podcast we needs money
we're gonna go look for a patreon that
doesn't exist
just send us a cash app
just kidding
yeah and that used to be in our bedroom
so i'm gonna decorate it somehow i don't
know i haven't really excited it's
perfectly fine the way it is that's so
cool if that was my like if i had a
murphy bed and someone came over and i
had to put the bed back up you just hear
like sand and crumbs
along the wall
crinkled up bags
that's how i hide everything quickly
when i have to clean
you're guaranteed to have at least one
cat jump on it every time this bed comes
down though
oh
dude where the hell did this come from
dummy and where'd it go like immediately
imagine you close it you forget he's in
there yeah you come with the wall
um yeah life is really different though
because
not only is it like just a new
environment at home which i've worked
from home for like a decade but uh so
like walking around the lakes like
there's lakes here i go rollerblading
for exercise now instead of my indoor
treadmill and uh la condo it feels just
more open and and free and then on top
of that like i've just been playing way
more poker
gina's actually gonna help me set up a
stream so i could stream my cool poker
tournament training
and i feel like you should do good with
that because like guys who like poker
would also like to watch a girl play i
think a hot girl so yeah you might do
pretty well yeah so like make sure i
put on makeup
like do the big titty poke related
things like yes you'll make some money
if you just play into it you know
like fake silicone upper bodies
for
drag queens yeah okay
i'm in
just when i first started playing poker
i was like i i'm gonna my goal is just
to be like an old weathered oh yeah
leather skinned
ex-smoker woman poker lady at the table
hit me literally
yeah
when are you gonna start smoking
you need to hurry up and start smoking
i know i need to get on that they're
outlawing the menthol ones though so
it's going to be hard to get addicted to
it because the regular ones taste no she
just needs a voice box thing and that's
it she said oh my god
[Laughter]
they make fake silicone ones with also
the voice box thing oh god
varicose veins
yeah yeah liver spots
yeah
perfect
perfect
yeah it's really cool also all of our
neighbors are about the same age and so
we have game nights all the time
not that i'm replacing you guys but like
um
definitely definitely you're like never
really
anymore so you totally replaced us we
definitely i
am there i was there today
okay
so you're welcome
give you a little slice of french with
your presents
yeah thank you
when are we heading over to vegas again
next month in the last month
i guess it's this month tomorrow oh yeah
that's right it's gonna be may oh my god
you guys are so predictable
thank you oh my gosh
yeah
catching up on the group chat though i'm
like oh this shower thing's really cute
that tip sent this like cat shower thing
and then gina does the same thing as me
okay so if you're gonna come knock me
out and come around judah and gina's
like what the [ __ ] happened to your hand
jess
a month ago
after it happened jess had some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] happen to her yeah tell us about
it what happened to you so i broke a
finger um i don't know if you can see
that it's still kind of red right here
so it's real it's swollen and red so i i
had surgery on it already so this is
basically this is the final stages of
the healing i just can't really bend it
so like
when i try to bend my hand like that's
kind of as far as it goes i don't know
if you can see like i really can't like
go back into a fist but so i was
uh gonna take my dogs with my dad to the
dog park but maddie
ran out the front door and you know my
dad was like up i guess we got to catch
maddie and then but he doesn't know that
like when you kind of chase after a dog
they think it's a game so they want to
run more
so like when a dog gets loose or at
least my dog the way she is like if you
kind of just don't chase her then she'll
she'll be like oh wait you don't you're
not you're not going to come chase me
like okay i'll come back you know like
she she she thinks if you go forward
she's going to keep going forward so
like don't keep going forward so anyways
it's like dating a man yeah yeah like
just act like you didn't
she'll come back yeah
so but anyway so she started running
down the street and then i was like okay
so then if i but what happens is if i
turn around and run the opposite
direction she'll realize i'm not chasing
her and she'll
she'll turn around and start running
she'll start running back make them come
to you there's this whole game with my
dog but so anyway i was trying to catch
her because i was like okay i'm not
gonna do this all day and we're in the
middle of the street so it's kind of
dangerous so i went down to try to catch
her
and in my head i thought oh i'll grab
the leash like i'll be able to catch her
if i grab the leash but with the amount
of force and how heavy she is she's like
45 pounds i caught the leash
but uh there's no way i was going to be
able to hold it because it was like
catching a [ __ ] car
and so i caught the leash it got stuck
on my finger just
just shattered my finger my finger was
like my finger was like this like
left
total left turn
oh my god almost 90 degree angle and
then so yeah i uh freaked the [ __ ] out
like i immediately saw it and yeah i was
just like
like which knuckle did it
it the knuckle didn't break it's the
bone like between the two oh
this is oh [ __ ] that's crazy
it snapped like the whole thing snapped
so i my finger was actually shattered in
three places so there was like a bone
kind of floating around in there
did it ruin your company volleyball game
yeah
jealous
those are basically done by the time
this happens so the the season's over
but yeah so then i had to get surgery
and um i got three pins in it and they
put these so they put pins through the
bone and it like sticks out of the skin
so i basically just had like wires
visibly exiting my skin for like
like crazy and so i would have to like
change the dressing and like wash around
these little wires that were sticking
out on my finger and like and it got
affected for a little while so to take a
round of antibiotics they said it's
almost impossible to have the these k
wires on your finger and it not get
infected just because like it's your
hands and it's
you know it's just hard to not get
infected so yeah but i basically i just
got the wires out like a week ago i
think or two weeks ago
but and so now i have to do physical
therapy to get the finger to bend
again but yeah that was very traumatic
and i like sometimes i have flashbacks
of the moment it happened and it just
like makes me want to
like just man it feels like trauma it's
like breaking bone is really like people
act like it's not that big of a deal but
it was it felt very traumatic to like
see a part of your body
like
not in the right position like it's just
freaky as [ __ ] so yeah i was it was hard
but now i'm kind of over it and it's
it's like the doctor did a good job
because like it's straight like you're
not gonna notice yeah like once this
redness goes away you're not gonna
notice that it was broken really
but um
is this your first broken bone yeah
i can't be part of that i read it
there's a subreddit called never broken
the bone
where it's just a bunch of it's like a
joke like it's not for really reals but
yeah
that um have never broken a bone before
and they're like yeah 32 years old never
broke a bone calcium buddies for life
like it's just like they brag about it
and then
everybody in the forum berates you and
kicks you out of the [ __ ] group
and they're really burnt off in the
funniest [ __ ] ways you [ __ ] weak
bone [ __ ] you
brittle bone [ __ ] and i just like it's
all in good fun it's not like for real
like your whole genealogy tree stole the
sunlight from grass
and your bones are dust
they're so good
so now you can't be a part of that
separated i made it to age 34 almost 35
i'll be 35 in june right yeah that will
smell so like a 50 year old would be
like that's pitiful i have almost twice
the amount of age you are you never you
didn't get a chance
you've never
my favorite is like they're sandwiched
in between like just really short
like braiding comments that are just
like go [ __ ] yourself
end your life
i swear we're friends
i want to see the bloody quarry pictures
did you see that you know
can you send it to me
you want to see i can send it to you i
was asking and i was like girl i don't
think you want to see this [ __ ] i know
you did surgical tech but this is gross
i know you told me you're like you're
gonna have nightmares like i don't know
if you wanna i believe you yeah i can't
handle it i mean you i mean if just
imagine a horror movie you've probably
seen something gross but i'm like you're
gonna see it on me and it might freak
you out i want it it'll see it it
changes
it to gina right now we can get her her
real-time reaction you guys can continue
talking because i gotta find it i need
the image of jess's hands to be frozen
in my mental memory space as being
pristine and perfect and this will taint
it for me
and i don't know if i could look at her
in the eyes anymore
oh my god oh my god i used to have my my
medical like lens before and i could see
gross stuff and be like oh that's
interesting like in a medical
perspective but that was like 10 years
ago like there's no i was like yeah just
i think you're right it's not really
going to give me anything it's not
really that bloody because um it was an
internal fracture so like
it's not like bone sticking out of the
skin but like that could show you the
whites sticking out of the skin
this is like right after the surgery
hold on let me see have you like broken
a bone no never
never
never there we go me neither
and i don't even drink milk i don't even
drink milk
don't even
oh [ __ ] since we last saw you
oh my god
i like i actually don't think i've ever
even sprained once i didn't think i ever
would i mean it's just really dumb to
think you can catch her you could catch
a running dog yeah yeah is it let me
show you what i get nightmares gina
would i get nightmares i know they just
think of finger with like like metal
three
uh three wires sticking out that's only
like two centimeters like one centimeter
long it's it's not bad there's only
another one i'm gonna send you another
one this is like right after it broke
when they straightened it before they
actually so like it was broken i didn't
get one when it was like 90 degrees but
this is when they try to like straighten
it after going to the er so like when
you break it it's all [ __ ] up then you
go to the er and then they try to
straighten it like they just trying to
pull like a splint
oh my god
i gotta yeah so you get a nerve block in
your [ __ ] in this joint right here
and it's one of the most painful things
ever like you think going to the dentist
and getting a nerve block you're like ow
but this is like
oh [ __ ] and then like and then like five
minutes later you're like okay thank god
it's gone
but like getting a nerve block in your
hand not [ __ ] easy it's [ __ ]
terrible oh my god yeah i should have
taken a picture when it was crooked but
i was too squeamish and i was like i
can't look at it i didn't even look at
it like i saw it once i was like oh my
god trauma right and then i covered it i
like just covered it and i was like
someone someone fix me someone yes fix
it it's broken i can't look at it fix it
what did your dad denial happen he was
just like oh [ __ ]
and he was like driving all erratically
like because he was freaked out i felt
bad for him that he felt i think he felt
bad he was like oh my god my daughter
just got hurt you know oh so it's like
no skin broke so there wasn't bleeding
it was just like crazy it was internal
like the bone just was crushed
internally yeah yeah
so if you try to move it it was just
like
it just was i couldn't it was it was
stuck yeah it's like because like
nothing broke like no tendons or
anything broke i don't think my joints
didn't break it was literally just that
little bone between the two joints
snapped and then but in like three
pieces
did you feel that snap
um
no honestly it it like happens so like i
felt like the the the leash whip out of
my hands like if you can can like
imagine like a leash whipping or like
when you whip a towel or something like
you kind of feel like like something
whipped out of your hand
but then i just looked down
like i didn't know that it was broken
but then i looked down and i was like oh
my god you know like i think you don't
feel that kind of thing right away yeah
because it's like shock yeah yeah it's
like that girl did you guys read the
story of that girl that lost her hand
when she was like she was like water
skiing and like the rope like basically
severed her hand off and she didn't
realize that it got severed off like it
just like went it just went so fast and
then she yeah
lannister
but imagine you're going water skiing
yeah
i'm [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
your tiny hands
shopping for new clothes can be time
consuming and stressful so why not let
stitch fix do all the work so you could
spend more time doing the things that
you actually love hello
it's easy and fun to get started first
what you're gonna do is you're gonna go
take a few minutes to set up your stitch
fix style profile you go online you
answer a few questions which is really
like looking at pictures and being like
i like this i don't like that i like
that i do not like this and then from
there they'll take your answers and a
stylist excuse me an expert stylist will
go to work finding items exclusively for
you every piece is hand-picked exactly
for your needs and it's unique to your
size style and in your budget making it
the best way to discover clothes that
make you look and feel your best without
having to like you know leave and go
places and and shop and like try things
on you know like that's annoying you
just do it from home hello
they also have this freestyle function
that i really like where if you know
what specific brands you like for
example madewell free people free
movement um all kinds of different
brands they're eluding me right now but
there's so many of them it's the what
brand don't they have really and you
just look it up and you go yes i'm gonna
select items from this brand and you can
just you can pick your own clothes if
you want but they have expert stylists
to do this all this work for you and
there's no subscription required you can
try it once or set up automatic
deliveries there are no hidden fees ever
so sign up today at stitchfix.com
mood to get 20 off your first purchase
that's stitchfix.com
mood to get dollars off your first
purchase limited time offer purchase
within two days of sign up thank you
fresh from san diego california comes
the only sunglasses brand that i have
been wearing recently i am talking about
blenders i wear and you're gonna be just
as hooked when you see how awesome these
shades are i got the mango muse shades
and they're so freaking cute they have
this cat eye style with gold tinted
lenses i'm obsessed you can see me
wearing them if you check out my vlog
channel tiffin case or on my instagram
i'm telling you i'm wearing these all
the time they're such good quality and
very sturdy too so i'm not worried when
the time comes that my baby luca will
get a hold of them chase fisher started
blenders by selling his beauty shades
out of a backpack while doubling as a
surf instructor on pacific beach his
goal to create an adventurous mid-priced
eyewear option with the same cool factor
as other leading styles unlike expensive
big brand shades that you've probably
lost or smashed in the past blenders are
actually affordable so you're not going
to cry as much when the inevitable
happens blender's team of in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles from orange polarized
wrap-arounds tortoise shell frames with
purple lenses to classic gold arms on
black lenses and it's not just
sunglasses blenders has prescription
glasses readers and blue lights as well
as a snow collection with goggles and
accessories live life in forward motion
with blenders today to score 15 off your
blender's purchase visit
blenderseyeware.com and enter promo code
big mood vip that's blenderseyewear.com
code big mood vip for 15 off blenders
rocked with pride worldwide oh my god
speaking of babyface when i see luka's
little literal baby face it reminds me
of you a lot how cute can you send me
pictures i can photoshop my fists on his
face
it is so cute cute i'm glad you're all
healed up jess
yeah i'm good now i mean i can't really
do much with this hand still but i'm i'm
okay i feel like it'll come back
eventually what's your pain skilled on
110 right now it doesn't hurt unless i
like just try to make a fist like if i
just leave it alone like if it's just
straight i feel nothing it's like any
other fingers it's just a little bit
right it's a little bit numb like
uh yeah or it's still healing like the
pin sights like the skin is completely
closed over now but it's still just numb
and it'll take a while were you able to
hold on to maddie with your other hand
while you were like screaming about your
hand yeah
my dad grabbed her yeah my diagram oh
okay i was just like
what was sophie like she just
yeah she doesn't run away or anything so
she was just like what
oh
looks like you're feeling better
yeah
all right what about you baby maker
i made a baby i made a baby
i know
like just voice messages of me just
berating the kid
i never met him bullying
yeah i'm pulling the [ __ ] out of that
newborn yeah i drank your mom's milk
[ __ ] that was yours i stole it
watch one day i i will play those
messages for him
wow
you sure she likes me
no but yeah i mean i haven't told you
guys my whole burst i did tell jess but
you know i didn't tell uh nikki and gina
my first story but there's an episode on
it um so that was pretty wild but having
luca in our lives it's been like a dream
like you guys know for how like
such a long time we've been trying and
trying to add to our family and now to
have him here it's like
we keep like he's
this week he turns three months so now
he's three months old and
casey and i are constantly like
oh my god we made him like he's here
like oh my god
every other day we're just like he's so
beautiful and so perfect and like he's
here and like we just constantly like oh
my god like that's that's our son like
he's finally here like your jeans mixed
with his genes made a person
yeah human being
yeah and just i don't know he's so
awesome like he's such a happy baby like
he's all every single where did that
where did he get that
yeah right
honestly
i think i think my life
changed a lot when i got pregnant with
him and so i've had a very different
life
since
like since i got pregnant with him and
it's just been a lot
less stressful a lot happier at home and
like you know casey and i relationship
is
amazing now and so like i feel like that
whole pregnancy and being so happy and
so content and like
so
i don't know another word for happy just
euphoric like it really translated to to
him i think and now
he's every single morning he wakes up he
has this big ass smile on his face like
he's just bright so his name luca it
means bringer of light and he totally
like is a bringer of light in my life
and so
every single day we're just like
in awe like we're just like oh my god we
love this kid so much he's he's awesome
so i can't wait for you guys to meet him
um
let's let me see i want i want the at
least our audience to get a little peek
out so let me go check on him oh bring
the little [ __ ]
i mean no whatever
i guess
my brain is doing that thing where it's
like don't say it don't say it don't say
it but bringer of light is also lucifer
but did you know that lucifer is also
actually jesus look it up look it up
look it up google it google it google it
google it
elizabeth and jesus are the same they're
the same [ __ ]
monster energy six six six
drink off and the devil wins
that video i love this video so much she
is [ __ ] insane i love it i've never
but seriously google is
lucifer is called the bringer of light
too and then jess was like lucifer and
jesus are the same person and then she
got all conspiracy oh she's like google
it look it up google it look it up look
it up
damn it nikki sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry
luke got lucifer oh my god yeah that
makes sense maybe it's a different
language but
you know what he's an angel he's an
angel my own kid's name
while you hear it
was dope though
and he was very very handsome
is into it she's like
the same person is okay he's the morning
star that's why he's the bringer of
light
okay well anyway he eliminates the mind
my angel luca my my non-darkness
the actual angel like my i don't know
how to save this okay
brain where it's like something gets
mentioned it's like oh [ __ ] i don't know
it's your autism we know it's okay
you're forgiven it's okay
it's not the same name
it's a different name okay it's
completely different and there's a whole
disney movie about it and disney is so
is the angel's gift
stop
you better stop
sorry the show's over oh my god we are
disbanding
i moved to vegas as i'm in the city sin
city and all we see is sin all you see
is my strength
you moved to the devil and you're trying
to spill it out on everyone else i moved
from the city of angels to the city of
sin you did it to yourself now
you're going to see my kid and now it's
it's just you're tainting it
you know like those videos where like
they introduce the baby to the dog at
home and the dog just kind of like
sniffs at it
and it just kind of looks at it it's
kind of i want to do a series of
pictures like that but me meeting the
baby for the first time
and you're holding the baby i'm standing
in the corner just
just slowly yeah that's cute it always
leads to a montage of the the dog and
the baby being best friends and they're
like
on each other
yeah
you're pulling each other's hair yeah
no that that actually has been the case
like with our cats like throughout my
whole pregnancy one cat wouldn't come
near me
uh so zoe was the boy
and maya she would always like cuddle up
with me even cuddle up with the belly
and all that and then after luka was
born she's the one that would like come
and like be curious and stuff and zou is
so funny every time luca cries he meows
like crazy like are you gonna shut this
kid up like what the heck
tend to this child like he's a
misogynistic cat get that [ __ ] cat
cause he's like he's just complains
every time and then it's crazy because
like i don't know i i think it's like
luka's frequency of his cry or something
but the cats like kind of attack each
other every time he's crying he has a
war cry
oh my so funny my dogs do that too when
something's really loud they start
fighting
yeah you know
you know i'll start in a war in heaven
make you turn your autism down a little
bit
damn who hates babies more now i don't
even know
i know
[Laughter]
i was not prepared for this
level one bullying i got like level
eight boys
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
oh my god i can't believe it i'm like i
don't know how to say this i'm not a
roaster back okay i know i'm gonna i'll
write you some
that
jesus and lucifer are the same person
yeah she did say that so thank you via
jess we're about to get some i guess
crazy religious nuts in our comments now
sage and selenite i could cleanse the
[ __ ] out of anyone that comes here so
it's fine
i'm gonna teach him how to you know
cleanse crystals and stuff and he'll be
he'll be a saint he'll walk he is a
saint already i know yeah well we'll
make it more of a saint make him turn
the water into wine and we'll all have a
party see
he's gonna learn a little bit from
everything
or from everyone i'm gonna teach him how
to tip
strippers really hard water all right
you know not gaming
teach him how to pick pocket
you know
he is one of these kids he doesn't need
these tools
he could be on that show uh old enough
japanese text pops up everywhere yeah
have you guys seen that show
no just so long so there's a show on
netflix it's an old japanese show called
old enough and it's every episode
follows a kid whose parents gave them a
task go to the local market and buy a
fish and bring it home and you know
japanese kids like they just do
everything on their own already they go
to school and stuff they fall like these
three-year-olds
and it's so funny it's so adorable
yeah because they get flustered or like
they're trying to carry like drag the
fish home
cute little hats and a sign that he
waves like please let me cross the road
it's so cute it's so adorable it's so
frustrating sometimes it's so sweet
because they're learning they're
learning how to be on their own
little kids like it could never happen
here yeah there's like little kids that
don't do their tasks like he was sent to
make orange juice but then he like just
[ __ ] around and played with a dog
outside instead
that's so cute
i only saw the trailer i didn't actually
watch the show really i just thought it
was cute
hi kitty hey hey
this is my princess hi
hi buddy oh so baby's sleeping right now
he's asleep right now i want him i
wanted you guys to see him does he wake
up if you pick him up no he's not crying
he actually struggles to nap during the
daytime oh
so like at night though he's awesome
like we have about we should have just
recorded this at night okay
no no he's
how much sleep are you getting lately
um
like some nights are good and other
nights are not great like last night
wasn't that great like
in the morning like from from three to
seven he was waking up like every
every like hour or like half an every
hour and a half or whatever oh man but
that's not always like for the most part
he actually sleeps from 7 p.m to 7 7am
he'll only wake up like twice or three
wow that's really good yeah so he sleeps
really for a new for new parents like
they're always like yeah bro i don't get
any sleep yeah three hours yeah it was
it was really rough in the beginning
because especially like i was
i was mainly handling luca in the middle
of the night because casey was he had a
ton on his plate during the day so i'm
like okay you rest
i'll take care of the baby throughout
the night and so
that got pretty pretty crazy for some
time but i'm like i did this before
because with isaac like i did that whole
thing by myself
yeah and having luca i'm like oh it's
okay i can do it and so i did like for
the most part i did watch him a lot
throughout the night but then i was like
okay casey i need a break like i feel it
and you're here thankfully you can help
so he ended up helping a lot more
throughout the
middle of the night but throughout the
day though casey's because he has to
work from home so it's amazing
having both of us be able to take care
of him like on and off like we'll take
turns and i'm like damn like even just
giving luca his first bath i was like
how did i do this for myself with isaac
like yeah that's actually insane i can't
remember like i honestly like the more i
deal with luca like the more i forget of
what it was like with isaac i guess it's
like replacing memories or something i
don't know but it is a 14 year gap so
and my memory is not that great so my
memory with isaac a lot of stuff has
been slipping away so i'm like mind
blown like how did i do this with isaac
like i don't i i can't remember and like
now tracking everything with luca like
his diapers and his like the feeding
like i time every time i breastfeed and
like which breasts and everything like i
have all the data of his life
it's crazy that i actually have it in my
phone like every single poop every
single p like
just everything what is the data for
it's really helpful actually okay oh
like we'll check the app we'll be like
oh how long ago did he have a diaper
change like oh [ __ ] it's been so many
hours like now it's time to change his
diaper even though like this um
it's funny because we actually got
sponsored by this diaper company good
hell yeah diaper nice
is a cody cody
cody here
what is it get it right
it's behind the scenes
so we actually got sponsored like big
move got sponsored by cody which is like
super luxury brand like diaper brands
and that diaper actually lasted the
whole night like a 12 hours from seven
to seven and i was like
this is like i was nervous because i'm
like oh my god he's gonna get diaper
rash and he was perfectly fine but
that's why like that data is really
helpful because i'm like oh man it's
been this long or he'll be fussy and i'm
like okay you i fed you i burped you
like what's going on and then like it
takes such a long time to like calm him
down or like to get him down for a nap
or whatever that next thing i know two
hours have passed by and i'm like
oh crap like i felt like i just fed him
but it's already two hours later so he's
hungry again
so i'm telling you my brain is not
reliable so so the app turns your kid
into a nano pet yeah like a sneeze
character pretty much yeah
yeah yeah
oh that's right there was tamagotchi and
nano bits i had a nano pet one hold on
what did it look like again
it was like a little triangle ones yeah
the bigger ones yeah the tamagotchis
were the the yeah
the other way around i had tamagotchi
yeah i can't remember i don't know that
means like like something like egg
friend or something all right i didn't i
didn't know that tomodachitomo
anyone listening that was like born in
the 90s or the 2000s even um this was
before we had cell phone apps so we used
to like
have these little nano pets they were on
your keychain and some people had like
eight of them yeah yeah yeah it's a
little too much but um they would like
poop and pee and stuff every two hours
and you'd like change their stuff or you
can feed them
you basically give them love too yeah
like a lovely option
that's right you're training us for this
yeah they were for the babies honestly i
remember like uh this girl she was like
i really wanted a kid and then my friend
told me to get a nano pet first and then
i was like oh no i can't handle the kid
she was like 20. yeah
that's great
i think it might have been her mom that
was like see if you can handle a kid now
dang she said it's like the hardest
level yeah
that's so smart yeah
every kid that once like every person
wants a baby super early give him like
eight tamagotchis yeah yeah and leave
all the volumes on yeah see what happens
that was the other thing too
like the furbies people had like
twenty-first yeah
yeah
no but you know it's crazy though like
with luca i was really surprised that
his first few because now he's three
months so like the first couple months
like he was
so good like he would never cry and like
never really fuss like he would just be
like
i don't when he was hungry obviously
he'd be like a little cranky but for the
most part like he was just always
smiling and like always like
in his sleep he'd be cracking up like it
was
adorable like he'd be sleeping he goes
i'm like what are you laughing at so
cute
but he's just constantly like so happy
he's a happy kid adorable and it's like
is that the love of my life it is i'm
[ __ ] worried about him that cat can
suck it
it's fun
you know that cat looks like we all know
that cat looks like
i'll tell you off camera oh okay no i'm
just kidding it's less about that but
that cat [ __ ] pissed all my stuff
yeah he will pee on uh guest things
my little nephew was over here over the
weekend and he has this little rhino
that he carries everywhere it's like his
little teddy bear and joe found it and
marked it he was like oh no no
i don't like this kid it makes too much
noise i'm gonna show myself yeah that's
hilarious he'll just get on his backpack
too yeah he peed on casey's backpack
backpack he didn't have his computer or
did it i can't remember we like to hide
your [ __ ] because he hasn't been peeing
on anything it was like he's been doing
really really good here but then
new people came over
and he was like ah
has been peeing lately on stuff because
i think he has a uti
um because your cat would have a uti
right
man
you're drinking enough water
seriously
he's a cat i truly deserve he is so he
is
on
medicated food forever because the
doctor said that's just how what he
needs now and because of covet and stuff
the ports and stuff are all backed up so
they didn't have the food anywhere for
two months so i had to feed him regular
wet food
they peed on my backpack and for some
reason he likes peeing on plastic bags
or any plastic that's on the floor
but which makes it easier because i can
just like yeah yeah bubble like gather
it up you know
yeah so that's what we're going through
right now my poor kid is so fun
bag specifically plastic bag so that
makes it easier to clean up yeah that's
awesome because this well my kid he
doesn't poop throughout the night he
only peed we're all right
that's amazing like you're like potty
training yourself already it's crazy
oh
that's been a nice perk also i want to
bring up the fact that like
like if you look at all of our
headphones it looks normal in our head
but on tiff's
because your head's so small but then
also the gray on the side makes you look
like you have gray mutton chops
if you have your hair back does it look
like princess leia dude
it's cute
you look like you know like you know
what you look like you look like
remember how like uh you know uh people
take babies at disneyland they don't
want their babies to hurt those giant
ear muffs don't you look like it's
precious
i know these are huge
you know how the horns kind of curl
around sometimes
oh my god
[Laughter]
that's hilarious i like that it was from
jk news
people i don't even know yeah she didn't
mean to i really didn't mean to and then
yeah
but
it's only because we're jealous because
tiff's i mean uh jess's baby broke her
[ __ ] finger and gina and i as babies
pee on everyone's [ __ ] and you're just
getting to smile through the night and
let you sleep and like you don't have to
get up
well let me make you feel better i have
gotten peed and pooped on so and okay
spit up on i don't even know about your
sex life tip yeah right why am i tired
we're talking about the baby here
changing subjects
and peter
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-proportioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellfresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
hello fresh offers convenient contact
free delivery right to your doorstep and
it's 30 cheaper than shopping at your
local grocery store plus you get to skip
the checkout lines recipes are easy to
follow and quick to make with steps and
pictures to guide you along the way
customize your favorite dishes with
their new hello custom offerings by
swapping out one protein or side for
another upgrading for a more luxe
experience or even adding protein to a
veggie meal that means more choices more
variety and more meals truly tailored to
you pick your favorites from 50
different weekly options and skip weeks
when you need to change your delivery
date or update your preferences all in
the hellofresh app they also have quick
and easy meals like 15 to 20 minute
dinners breakfast on the go and 10
minute lunches in the hello fresh market
perfect for your busy schedule i
personally love hello fresh because one
of my favorite recipes that they offer
is the figgy balsamic pork and what i
love is that they send me all the
various ingredients in the right amount
so that i can make the sauce for the
pork but if i were to not get the meal
honestly i wouldn't want to go to the
grocery store and buy all the various
different things i would need in order
to make that sauce so i love that they
just send me just enough that i need for
a meal or two and i get to enjoy that
figgy balsamic pork without having to
buy all these various ingredients and
then have a crap ton of stuff in my
kitchen get america's number one meal
kit go to hellofresh.com big mood 16 and
use code big mood 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts again go to
hellofresh.com big mood 16 and use code
bigmood16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts dudes laundry never
stops in this house like every day i'm
doing a load of laundry
every day
almost every day it's like every other
day like spit up towels and stuff yeah
like all the baby clothes
it's just it all it's always getting
when does isaac become a built-in nanny
yeah never you guys get date nights ever
no never
like man no
useless
no so i told so you know like having
isaac like having a teenager everyone's
like oh you're gonna have so much help
yeah i'm like no
because he wants it he refuses no no i
refuse i refuse to put that pressure on
my kid like i refuse to make him like
have to take care of his little siblings
yeah what if he was like um you like you
paid him like a babysitter do you think
he'd be into that because like teenagers
so he can make the choice
yeah he can make a choice i mean he
wants to hold him he's like really
hesitant because he's he's scared of
like getting him sick because uh because
isaac goes to school so he's always like
oh i don't want i don't want to get my
little brother sick so like he'll he'll
be very careful even just to hold him or
to kiss him but
like so even with that like i can sense
that he's just like i i'm not
comfortable dealing with him at all like
in in any like other than like sitting
down and holding him for a little bit
and like talking to him from like kind
of a distance like he's he's like kind
of warming up to the fact that
he has a baby in the house because he's
not used to that especially because luka
was preemie
and so he was just really like
like fragile and so he was just really
afraid and but now that luca's getting
older and he's more sturdier like just
today earlier as i was doing my makeup i
had to like wash my hands really quick
so i'm like oh isaac would you mind
holding luca really quick and so he's
like okay so he held him and like he
walked that was the first time he walked
with luca like he he was walking from
one end of the room to the other to go
sit down and i was like oh that's the
first time you've been on the move with
your brother because it's always been
like he's always been like frozen
he's just like i don't know what to do
with this kid and so
anyway yeah like
if he would ever like decide to be like
oh yeah hey mom like you know i'm down
to watch luca like i'm all for it like i
will welcome that it's just i refuse to
yeah to put that pressure on him because
i was i was my little brother's second
mom like i
said and like clean them and like
took care of them like i disciplined i
did everything you felt like that
affected you negatively though
i feel like i mean obviously your mom
was a little bit too
you know like not present but like to
interact busy working and stuff and like
like it's just i feel like
yeah it did negative effect
uh what is it negatively affect me
because
i no longer was able to be a sister yeah
as a mom
and i i couldn't especially with the
huge age gap that i had with my my
little brothers
like i didn't have that bond with them
like i wasn't able to bond with them as
a sibling and instead i actually
grew resentment as a child towards these
little kids even though it wasn't their
fault it's like a burden yeah it was a
burden like i really felt that and so i
that's why like with that isaac and with
luca i'm like no like i would never know
that like i guess because i was more of
a single child i mean i have a brother
but and i had to take care of my brother
a little bit when he was a baby but he
we got separated pretty quickly when i
was younger so i just remember those
times of like me teaching him how to put
the little
little shapes and little thing like my
mom wasn't around so like i had to like
watch him and then like i would change
his diaper and that would be like
[ __ ] weird or whatever but then like
when that got taken away
when we got separated i felt sad i think
from that
so i can't imagine that i yeah that it
would be negative to have to like take
care of your but obviously you've had
that experience so it is possible
yeah yeah i think because it's like
forced upon you instead of like
like you didn't like i got forced upon
yeah i mean my mom was an alcoholic so
like i had to watch my brother right so
but like yeah so i think yeah that's
true yeah no for sure i and then but
you're closer in age with your brother
right he's yeah it's seven year
difference oh okay it's not
so i was like seven years old watching
him yeah
you guys i've never changed a diaper
still
what never changed a diaper no like your
nephew do they have a reddit for that
right
never changed
35 years
[Laughter]
are you sure about that with your
husband no
he's never naked so
he's in never mind that's true never
seen his butt
crazy thing
[Laughter]
we don't see butts no it's cool that
you're you're doing that too because
like especially ethnic families i feel
like that's where the first board is
always there to raise the rest of the
kids yeah yeah it's cool that you're
doing that
yeah because i mean i'll ask him too i'm
like oh like you know
would you like to know how to change a
diaper he's like oh no i'm good i'm like
okay cool hopefully this keeps him from
getting anyone pregnant too young right
being exposed to a baby already he won't
like make any mistakes like you know
yeah actually i feel like
it's funny because i feel like me taking
care of my little brothers made me want
to have a baby sooner because you're a
girl
well because it's like you're already a
mom like you're already like being like
a mom so it's
yeah it would be my own kid exactly but
for me it was because like
i mean it sounds bad on my mom but i'd
be like oh okay
i want to have a kid so i can show you
what it's like
how to do it damn girl jeez i know i'm
like damn holy that's literally the
thought process when i was younger and
so yeah i got pregnant at 17. tiffany
real dude jesus christ
you have to score your mom real quick on
babies
yeah because i'm like dude like because
i would get so angry too like i'd be
disciplining my brothers and i'm like
teaching them like no you don't do this
or like you do or whatever you know like
i yeah i'd have them on check and my mom
would come in and like just give them
whatever because they'd be crying and
i'm like you're spoiling like you're
undoing all the hard work yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you know what i'm gonna show you
how to do this i feel like that's that's
what dads get to do yeah it's like moms
are always the one like
laying down the law because they're
there the whole time and then the dad
comes over and says i brought candy yeah
so
frustrating oh yeah
no and then like that's literally been
the case like with
with isaac and with casey obviously
casey is a step dad so he there's like a
weird like as much as he wants to be his
dad like there's a weird boundary there
where he can't be the bad guy
and so
in our
in like this whole family dynamic with
our blended family like i've always had
to be the bad guy yeah so now
like with having luca in the picture i
told casey i'm like
time for you to step up yeah you get to
be the bad guy because
like i i also didn't want him to be the
bad guy with isaac because yeah it's
just it's gonna grow resentment like
create resentment or whatever because of
that weird
boundary that's
well that's the right unfortunately
there yeah so now with luca being here
we're like well let's see what happens
like
the whole thing is dynamic how is casey
doing honestly as a father
he's not listening right now
no actually i was about to say that when
joe popped up i was like you know what
the most beautiful thing about all this
though having luca around is seeing
casey like with his own like flesh and
blood baby demon spawn
and like seeing him like just fall in
love and like being such a good dad and
attentive and stuff and like
and so casey entered isaac's life when
isaac was four about to be five so like
the talent of being four years old
and so he didn't he missed all this with
isaac yeah so he's just he's constantly
saying like you know
having luca in his life now makes him
appreciate isaac more and like makes him
like
see
isaac in a different light because like
he's like i missed all this with you but
doing it with luca it's kind of like
getting to do it with isaac sort it like
i don't know how to explain it but like
it's kind of like
it just makes him appreciate like he
thinks about isaac while he's also
taking care of luka maybe and you can
kind of like
feel both of them there being at the
same time kind of like oh man like
imagine me doing this with isaac too
exactly so crazy yeah that's cute yeah
and then like dealing with isaac now
that now that he's 14 and stuff like
seeing him as a 14 year old like we've
like i forever see him as my baby and
casey is like i've all i've forever seen
him as that four-year-old that i met
but now like getting to go like move
through the emotions of like having luka
changing a diaper and burping like doing
all the baby stuff like now i get to
kind of like imagine exactly what just
saying like imagine it with
isaac so it just makes him
appreciate him that much more and like
makes you feel that's unexpected that's
cool yeah
so sweet i just want to i just want to
smell the baby i like the new baby smell
yeah you know the top but i don't and i
think that's why i shouldn't be a mother
i don't like
i like the smell of new babies i go ugh
maybe if it's yours it's different it
might be a different one like when it's
no because people like other people's
baby babies all the time and i'm like i
don't like smell baby
there's always that one [ __ ] that's
like i never liked kids and then i had
you
seriously
ain't no baby coming out of here
you know it's crazy i can't really smell
luca because
you're in it all the time
i can't smell he started developing this
really adorable like right here in like
the top of his head like sour smell
but it's like
it's like
it's cute though it's like that weird
smell you can't stop smelling like oh
yeah i like my dogs like you know what
dog smell a lot of people don't like the
way dogs smell but like i can
get right up in there and go
oh smell like dog
nice yeah i like the ducks i like the
smell of cat spit like when they're
cleaning themselves
i like that smell
yeah like it's like a i don't know how
to describe it it's like kind of like
what you're talking about like a little
bit sour but it's like you i don't know
i know like cat breath i don't like
happiness no not cat breath that's fishy
yeah when they're like licking
themselves it's like a cleaner
i don't know how to describe it but yeah
i'm like that's my [ __ ] cat my baby
has like no smell that's why i like it
like he has no like if you just
shove yourself his breathing smell no
breath no oh i never even i have never
even heard or smelled him fart
well your bathroom smells
yeah right yeah
that's a cat smell that's not the cat
that's the just the litter box yeah yeah
so
everything else
now i wonder like how come
sometimes like before i remember before
i got a cat you go to like people's
houses and you just smell cat yeah what
is that because i've never had that you
i've never been i've never smelled it in
you guys houses
really i smelled it in nicki's house
really i smelled it in your house well
your bathroom yeah that's a litter box
smell but there's like a general like
cat smell yeah yeah i don't think you
would smell it at our house now because
all the litter boxes are so like
hidden and the house is so much bigger
and area yeah
you'd smell it now there's no litter
boxes downstairs do you smell dog smell
when you come to what you guys didn't
come to my place very much do dogs not
really i think you could eat too much
smell i always smell cleaner when i'm
like yes
i do clean way too much
her favorite air freshener is windex
have you been able to clean as much with
having a nine to five and a broken
finger
yeah yeah like because i get to work
from home so i'll take my lunch break or
whatever and i'll like be doing laundry
and i'll be like doing dishes and stuff
so i kind of like i'm not at the office
all the time i'm only going like twice
twice a week maybe
so i still cleaned a lot you're like i
can't wait to clean
honestly it feels like a break from
something mentally taxing so it's like a
chance for me to get into the zone in
like a different way so it does feel
like a break cleaning feels like a break
i wish i had that it was my nightmare
it's enjoyable for me
what's going on in your life gina you
didn't even talk about your life your g4
show you got so many shows oh yeah um so
i picked up a new show
it's the official like dungeons and
dragons show it's like animated
no like it's live it's us but we haven't
seen where you met freddy prince uh no
that was on a different show on g4 this
one's a different show that's actually
what dungeons and dragons the the
company that creates it to the coast wow
yeah so we have like
um we have a main cast i'm part of main
cast and we have rotating uh guests that
come in so we had like brandon lee
mulligan
we had deborah ann wall so we have like
all these really cool people come in and
play with us
and
they wanted to make a
like artwork of all of our characters
and make like a poster and we had like a
theme song and everything it was so cool
available for download yeah
and then uh so the artist was really
cool he i hit us up he said i need like
six photos of just your face and then
describe what you want your character to
be and the the character i'm playing
she's from her basically her race is
called the candors and candors are
basically even no matter how old they
get they look like children
like children
yes true
maniac child
so we have that show
g4 has been keeping me really busy and
um
oh right we went to our very first
convention together as a company like a
gaming convention
it was our first public appearance
and uh and outings together is in boston
it's at a convention called pax and we
had a panel
and a meet and greet
and i i read this on facebook my old or
my personal facebook the other day where
it felt like i was on the flight to
boston and i realized that i used to get
hired to be just like a booth babe at
these conventions and just stand there
and now i'm like on the main panel yeah
the biggest conventions i was like oh
that's so cool
and
i was talking to my co-hosts and we were
all like yeah like it'd be cool like
imagine like 50 people showed up that'd
be so neat so we ended up filling the
room's capacity at 600.
wow capacity was 600 we failed at 670
and they had to turn people away at the
door
and we were like amazing yeah we were
blown away we saw like my friends were
waiting in line also from new york as
they were in town and they took pictures
like look there's these people standing
in line
i was like for what
because for your panel i'm like are you
sure
so we filmed it
it was yeah and it was our first time
being able to see people in real life
and see the fruits of our labor you know
yeah do you know how the numbers are on
the g4 show like do they share that
stuff with you like is it is they
use they do i just don't really pay
attention yeah
sounds like you yeah you know because
when it comes to logistics any
analytical stuff i'm out like i'm just
here to [ __ ] [ __ ] up and do stupid
things and everything you're a contender
i'm a counter yeah
um
so i have that show for uh d d it's
called legends of the multiverse
it's a very it's a dungeons and dragons
um
game but imagine it in space and it's
very uh guardians of the galaxy like
oh okay yeah so it's fun do you dress up
do you wear costumes yeah oh i [ __ ]
love dressing up because my characters
it's so cute um
yeah so we we had the convention that
was great our meet and greet was
supposed to only be for an hour but we
went for two hours
and we had to turn people away at the
door too because it was like that's
awesome yeah
and then it was just like we we all kind
of sat down afterwards like holy [ __ ]
like this is actually like it's working
like
people like us you know
um
so that's been really fun
uh it's been extra busy lately i feel
like
but it's it's been it's been a good
visit yeah and then i have a new um i
picked up a third show
um that will be airing
later on this year
uh it's we start filming in june
hopefully um i can't talk about it yet
but i'm super [ __ ] excited nice
yeah i'm really really excited
um
and then hopefully by the time this this
episode comes out i've been waiting on
word for a photo shoot for
what would be like
the biggest brand i'll ever have ever
worked with in my life wow and it's
really big brand so that's like saying
something
yeah
this brand would be like i can guarantee
you everyone will know exactly what this
brand is can you text me who it is i
know it's a group chat
okay fine here here but like
so you can see your live reactions
um
who is it who are you getting to work
because i feel like you've already
worked with really big stuff i know
exactly that's what i'm saying
it's exciting gina what the [ __ ]
what
shut up
do
yet
crossing fingers do you have a contract
yet no not yet because like they're
they're still like going back and forth
and like figuring [ __ ] out and it was
supposed to be
this past week but then like um they had
to push it back a month i'm like bro
just [ __ ] tell me my asian guy
my agent's pissed he's like brother what
the [ __ ] man
like i know i want to know so bad so i'm
like i'm crossing my fingers and that
would be so sick
that is sick
yeah it's awesome
oh yeah you get money right okay i'm
like yeah yeah i'm like
did they do that did i do this [ __ ]
we're like you sh you should be lucky to
work no no no no i don't think should be
that's though and the agent wouldn't be
mad at all yeah that's true yeah
so hopefully by the time this episode
comes out we find out if i get it or not
if i don't that's fine you know
well you're getting a lot of stuff
you're already getting like the universe
is pouring yeah
yeah you deserve every single bit of
that okay okay you just that's really
difficult
thank you i'm so proud of you thank you
and then like it's
oh i hope i don't know maybe i don't
want the decision yet because nikki just
told us that mercury is in room
and i don't know like i don't well no
it's not not there yet so like you got
like anything that started before the
room baton is okay oh okay and then
during it if you start something during
it that was almost it didn't start
during it so exactly you're okay
negotiation started like two weeks ago
we're good okay hell yeah
uh but i'm just i'm just [ __ ] i'm just
so [ __ ] busy man like i'm waking up
early i had to be
in the studio at seven a.m the other day
and a part of me
died that i will never get back okay
i'll never get it back
uh
you're still not used to her like long
days now after having nine to five type
of schedule no not at all
or do you just think um
whenever it depends so like on our big
show days it's
like 9 00 a.m to 7 p.m
um on lighter days i just come in for
one meeting and i'm good or like on
medium days i come in to film like a
couple things and i'm out by like three
or four
um
it's for the most part it's it's it's
fine but then like i have the dnd show
which films in the evening from like
five to eight
so there are some days where i'm doing
two shows in one day oh yeah that's a
lot for one day yeah yeah
it's so odd every time i get a text from
jean at like 8 30 in the morning i'm
like yeah that's the right name did you
i'm i just think you never went to sleep
did you yeah yeah
that's true
and then like the morning that i had to
wake up and be there at seven
i whenever i have to show up super early
for something i get anxiety the night
before because i'm afraid i'm gonna miss
my arms and i don't sleep yeah so i
slept for like 30 minutes oh no
and then
filmed and then i told g4 i was like i'm
not gonna drive home yet because i don't
think i can i might pass out so i went
to my dressing room and i tried to lay
there but then i stared at the wall for
like three three hours yeah what and i
and then i couldn't sleep
for the rest of the night i was up for
this was literally last night i was up
for 24 hours
i could never do that
i went to sleep this morning six am or
six a.m
oh yes yeah you need to find times where
you'll just take a pill and sleep for
like 14 hours because you're going to
need it yeah and then it doesn't help
that this past week we just got back
from boston also so it was kind of like
everything was because you're doing so
much yeah yeah careful don't burn out
get your sleep get your rest in there
the best thing about it is that drink
lots of water doing this so much that i
don't even feel an ounce of oh i don't
want to you know like i am so happy in
it yeah that's the only way you can pull
those kind of hours is loving it it has
to be something that you really love
yeah yeah for sure that's really awesome
so i don't know when i don't know when
this episode is going to come out but
let you guys know a week or two
yeah oh okay about that shooting or if
we go public with the third show that
i'm on but other than that sweet just
working man commuting this war over
there is jack up the gas prices
oh my gosh these are so expensive you
know the one year that i commute gas is
[ __ ] through the roof oh yeah
i've got a break
tiff can you go steal your son my my
computer is about to die and i can't
plug it in okay
can we see i've got 13 percent left okay
let me know
look we're only on the episode with
bringing the baby over here i might
disappear so yeah
i gotta get my selenite
what is that oh
my
god can't with you nikki put it away
nikki
it's really quick on your screen
put it away
don't tell her don't show
that feels so bullied right now
no i love her i'm so sorry
it's so good
she's the one person that doesn't like
me roasted too i tried
i'm like don't roast too i wasn't even
trying
okay i was trying with those once you
said it's the first time you should have
said it again
no then i have to double down after that
damage is already done listen there's
another person
there's another person named luca that
if i told tiff she would not like it at
all so i've kept it to myself lucas you
should say it you should know it out
even
good friend
my brain won't let me not oh hi little
baby yeah what's up [ __ ] me
don't let him hear you be nice oh
he was healing just now he's like why
did you wake me up no he was eating in
okay
baby oh he's very mad
yeah he was it's it's left i can't speak
oh my poor babies oh my god they like
they like visuals can you see color here
[Music]
look at the pretty colors
there you go
yeah look at this
look at that it's looking good
me and gina baby babysitting
in case he was like oh trying to feed
him oh i see some of my frozen breast
milk
so right now he's
he's not in the best neighborhood
keep breaking keep shaking yeah
keep going keep going
i'm not changing the diaper though i'm
in a subreddit
[Applause]
it gets heated up girl
like breast milk italian ice cream oh
god but if it's like soft would it be
like yogurt like those frozen yogurt
things you know
i don't know we always heat it up
just give me some ice cream every once
in a while when he's teething the ice is
good for him oh yeah no i'll definitely
do that like i just picture you guys in
vegas and uh gina is casually licking a
frozen
popsicle good yeah
do you ever meet myself in irene like
that one scene where like he's literally
like sucking on the woman's breast no i
don't i don't remember that i remember
the boys oh yeah well yeah oh actually i
think they cut it out it was like a
deleted scene i don't know whatever the
point is
luca's here hi i remember a game at game
of thrones that kid on the booth oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh god i am that kid
it's good that you're self-aware all
right
hi luca
hi baby yeah you're so cute
not for free
[Laughter]
look at his little hands
i know he's so cute he's the best oh my
god goodness he's like a whole person
his arms are like actual arms right no
not little baby t-rex things anymore i
know you know what
you know like some babies are hairy is
he harry oh when he was first first born
because he was a preemie it's called lit
length
yeah
yeah yeah and
like his whole body was like covered in
a lot of little hairs because that's
supposed to like go it's like help it
helps you warm up it's like people with
some eating disorders get it too because
like they don't have enough to keep
their body weight oh i didn't know that
wow
yeah so he looked like a hairy little
monkey when he was first born because he
was so skinny too yeah because he was
only five pounds when he was born oh
[ __ ]
how does the hair go away just like fall
out does he like it just felt like he
sheds like a cat that's cool i mean it's
such a thin tiny little hair like a
snake it's just like a
full
hair baby
gina would want to keep it in a case if
that happened yeah i would i would it's
funny no it's like such just like it's
just so small you can't even see it oh
but even like his head hair like in his
crib i could see because he has a white
sheet in his crib you can see some of
his baby hairs
like he is shedding some of his babies
[ __ ]
[ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
you know it's really weird um a
postpartum symptom
of mine is not losing my hair where i'm
like oh because with isaac i totally and
everyone like every mom like it's super
comedy you just lose a ton of hair
and
with luca i actually am losing less hair
in the shower okay like barely like two
or three strands that come out in the
shower
before jesus right a little ball
i told you he's jesus cool
and like with with luca too
oh
shut up baby's complaining so much
it's the best when he's like upset and
then i give him the pacifier or i'm
feeding him and he goes
babies with attitude seriously yeah wait
is he coming to vegas
yeah yeah music yeah whatever yeah
oh my god i'm so excited
yeah
look it's just so smooth you finally
meet them
for the audience uh listening and
watching this is literally the first
time that these [ __ ] are meeting luca
yeah not even on facetime
i tried it facetime i know but i was
feeding him okay
i know
i didn't warn you i just i know you just
called and then i told you like let's
face him tomorrow and i miss that
because everything is because we're not
friends when i play poker i just shut
everything off she got trapped in her
murphy bed
[Laughter]
okay well that's uh that's our episode
of catching up and i hope you guys
enjoyed it you know we're i think next
time we film is it next time that we
film yeah we'll all be together we'll
all be together we'll be meeting a baby
like a happy family that's right baby a
happy family
all right you're stealing my spotlight
shut up already excuse me um but we're
gonna be meeting luca for the first time
also in person
uh but thank you guys for watching
thanks for hanging out with us make sure
you guys follow us follow all the uh
links down below in our description
boxes and and and and buy stuff from our
sponsors because we gotta feed this damn
baby yeah until next time wait wait you
know what we didn't mention the fact
that this zoom episode is taking place
in three different states
oh yeah we're in three different states
oh yeah
yeah mickey's in tri-state
jess is in texas tips in california i'm
in the state of depression
all right thank you guys for watching we
love you and we'll see you guys next
time
[Applause]
[Music]
you